foreign
[Music]
coming up thousands of Ukrainian
children have been forced to live in
Russia without their parents we hear
from the children now reunited with
their Dads back home
also coming up and what is the
government's foreign secretary doing to
help children caught up in war one of
the most senior politicians in the UK
agrees to take my questions
thank you
welcome to FYI the show where we bring
you all the latest news all the big
stories and this week There's a couple
of stories that caught our attention
[Music]
history has been made in Scotland Hamza
Yusuf became the country's new first
minister
Hamza is the first Muslim to take the
top job and said he was a proud Scott he
felt like the luckiest run in the world
to take over the role as the head of the
Scottish government from Nicholas
sturgeon I will dedicate every waking
moment to serving you
the people of Scotland
a report by the children's commissioner
who investigates issues affecting young
people revealed nearly 3 000 children
were stopped and searched by police in
England and Wales from 2018 to mid-2022.
the report showed that black children
are more likely to be searched now we
found out that police are only allowed
to search children if they are suspected
of a serious crime with a parent or
Guardian moved them in the police
station but it seems these rules have
not always been followed the government
and Children's Charities are demanding
an explanation
[Music]
now another big story that we've
reported on is the United Nations
International investigation which
revealed thousands of Ukrainian children
have been forced to live in Russia
the report says they're being taken by
Russian soldiers and forced to live with
foster parents or in orphanages in
Russia
many are struggling to get in touch with
their parents it's believed that they're
being educated to become more Russian
and forget their Ukrainian roots
an arrest warrant has been issued for
the country's President Putin and its
children's minister
[Music]
some of these children are being Freed
From Russia and returned to their
families like matsvi and his two sisters
this is their story
foreign
[Music]
no windows nothing this was the safest
place
we drew
the basement had lights so we drew
we had toys so we played we had problems
with the water supply electricity so we
had the wheel we made candles out of
bandages and oils you must use them to
light up the room
Matthew's father yevin was captured by
Russian forces in the Ukrainian city of
mariopol which has seen some of the
worst fighting of the war yevin was put
in jail and Matt Vienna's two sisters
were taken to Moscow and put into a camp
when they took my dad away I tried not
to think about it nobody explained
anything to us
one man said he would be returned in
seven years
[Music]
with food but we could not eat what we
wanted
[Music]
when his dad was eventually released
mapley managed to call him and explain
he was in a camp near Moscow but was
about to be sent to either an orphanage
or a Russian boss of Abilene
um we could take you to a foster family
for a bit until your dad picks you up oh
we can take you to an orphanage
you know I said I won't tell them until
they let me speak with my dad
Matthew's dad knew he had no choice but
to act quickly
he walked through towns as they were
bombed and crossed the border into
Russia where he was eventually reunited
with his children
with the help of volunteers the family
were then able to flee across the border
to the safety of neighboring Latvia
[Music]
it's an incredible Story I mean I'm so
happy that they're back safe with their
Dads yeah I mean it's amazing they're
all reunited
[Music]
you've probably
talked recently about Tick Tock
governments and organizations across the
world have banned employees from having
tick tock on their work phones because
of security concerns
it's all because of what tiktok does of
the information it collects from the
people who use it which some say is
being given to the Chinese government of
course Tick Tock is only for people aged
13 or over but these concerns about
China have led to many people
questioning whether they should continue
using it well we're going to be talking
more about China later with one of the
most influential politicians in our
government the foreign secretary but
first what exactly is going on with Tick
Tock and what does it mean for us well
we decided to ask Netflix Navara is a
social media expert and he's come to
answer some of our questions hi Matt
hey
so Matt why is the UK government and
others decided to ban Tick Tock well
Tick Tock is owned by a company called
bite dance which is a Chinese company
and in China the government there can
ask any company at any time to hand over
information and data about any of its
users so the UK government like others
is worried that if ministers and
politicians are using it on their work
devices with private and confidential
government information on those phones
there could be a risk so what is data
and how can it be so harmful well data
in Tick Tock is about all of the
information that we give it really or it
learns about us so when we give it our
date of birth where we're located or the
things that we like and the things that
we share on Tick Tock all of that
information is data that can be saved
and stored by the app or by the company
and I guess we need to be assured we
know who's using that information so if
Government ministers aren't allowed to
use it why should we I mean should we be
worried I don't think that we need to be
worried too much you know the government
is thinking about the ministers with all
of the government information which is
going to be some of it private and
confidential and important and for
everyday users like me and you it's not
so much of a concern because what we're
doing on the app although it's not
unimportant it probably isn't as
interesting to the likes of a Chinese
government well thank you so much for
joining us Matt
[Music]
time now for me to meet one of the UK's
most important politicians the foreign
secretary James cleverley he agreed to
talk exclusively to FYI about his job
and all the things that are keeping him
busy at the moment
so what does the foreign secretary do
and why is it an important job so the
foreign sector is in large part I think
the face and the voice of the UK on the
world stage my job is to talk to other
governments
protect British Nationals when they're
overseas and try and improve the
relationship between the UK and other
countries around the world
one of the things that must be at the
top of your agenda is the war in Ukraine
so shouldn't we be doing more to help
the ukrainians we're one of the first
countries in old to provide military
equipment support to the ukrainians and
training before the full-scale invasion
in February of last year but also
British families have taken Ukrainian
refugees into their homes and we've
provided over 200 million pounds of
humanitarian support and 2.3 billion
pounds of of military aid
[Music]
the UK's relationship with China has
long been questioned because of how it
treats its own people and it's one of
the biggest contributors to climate
change and despite the UK and several
other countries Banning any trade with
Russia until it stops its invasion of
Ukraine China has announced a massive
trade deal with Russia to help its
economy China's president Xi Jinping
seems to be getting very close with
Russia's President Putin so are you
worried about China getting involved
with all of this we've made it clear
that we would be
completely opposed to China supporting
Russia militarily the response we've had
from China is that they're not intending
to do that and I hope that they Stitch
their word so do you see China as a
threat to World Peace China is a a
powerful wealthy influential country on
the on the world stage but China has
behaviors stories conductive behaviors
we are deeply opposed to but we are
always looking at ways to engage with
China to to try and improve the
relationship between the UK and China
and and try to influence China to take a
better a more positive path
[Music]
climate change is a huge threat to all
of us so do you think we're doing enough
to encourage other countries to cut down
on their carbon emissions well actually
your question's right in in saying that
it's not just about what we do
domestically in the UK it's about what
we do internationally over the last
decade
China has emitted more greenhouse gases
more carbon emissions than the UK has
done since the Industrial Revolution so
that's the kind of scale that we're
talking about but how can we lecture
other countries when we're building new
coal mines and gas and oil fields it's
not just lecturing other countries it's
helping other countries there's no point
in US pointing to countries and say you
should change your behavior what we need
to do is to say look we are going to
help you so why are we building new coal
mines and not using renewable energy
then well renewable energy doesn't work
all the time and it doesn't work in
every circumstance and actually we want
to be in a situation where we never have
to burn a single ounce of coal ever
again we are not quite there yet
women and girls are staging protests
about having more freedom you know
freedom to live more freely and wear
what they want to wear so do you support
these women girls and if so what are you
doing to help them I've made it clear to
the Iranian authorities they should
listen to their own women
these women are are demanding only what
is completely legitimate and that is to
be respected within their own country
and of course we support their aims so
do you think that's enough well the the
work to make the lives of women and
girls better around the world whether it
be in Syria Afghanistan or anywhere else
will never be finished it's something
that we're going to have to work on
every single day in every single corner
of the of the world
[Music]
inspired to take his artwork to new
heights this artist has launched his
first art exhibition into space
this out of this world exhibition
features a balloon dog sculpture and a
golden break dancing astronaut alongside
a 360 degree camera to capture the
journey into space cool
foreign
are you a fan of the Roald Dahl books
well they're just absolute classic books
I think almost all kids read them
growing up and some of them are now
movies my favorites were always James
and the Giant Peach and Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory well you know some of
his books have been tweaked and
re-released because some people think
the language just isn't appropriate for
today yeah well not everyone's happy
about that some people think we should
learn from the mistakes of the past
rather than get rid of them completely
well Publishers say they will continue
to offer the original books where there
are actually loads of new versions of
his work including the revolting rhyme
film which I want to see accompanied by
a live Orchestra check this out
[Music]
all right
I've come to watch a vaulting Rhymes
which adapts role dance poems it's a
funny old Twist of old fairy tales like
Cinderella it's Red Riding Hood Snow
White Jack on the Beanstalk and just so
many more and it's not often you get to
watch a film with a live orchestra
playing at the same time
[Music]
you have to be very quiet because
they're performing right now but you see
that man all the way down there that
that's a conductor his job is to make
sure the orchestra pays everything at
the right time how often do you conduct
music performances for kids well I
probably do about five or six a year I
like having kids in the arms because
they let you know what they think you
know you're with an adult audience
they're all completely silent you've got
no idea so what's the most difficult
thing you have to do as a conductor
people don't really know about it's just
being a focus for all of that Talent
really all of that skill just in one
place so that we're all doing the same
thing for the same reason and actually
that's the reason that it's great to
watch because you see 50 people I can't
think of anywhere else where you have 50
people there's not only that many people
on a football pitch you know who are
really coming together to achieve one
thing and that's great to see I think
and lovely to do
thank you
so how is it how you guys feeling it was
pretty good I think that the orchestra
did a really good performance of it it
was quite a magical experience it was
really nice to figure out and notice how
well the music was played it was really
enjoyable I really like laughed at
moments and thought it was sad at
moments is really good and I've never
actually been to a live Orchestra before
so it was really exciting I didn't think
it would be so cool
[Music]
how
of doing a
Wonder of us we had a whole orchestra
playing the music the difference is it's
like better because they're actually
really then you get to see them very
impressive they must have had a long
time of training I just don't really
know how they keep all those notes in
their head
Roald Dahl's books poems films are
universally loved they've been around
for so many generations and until now I
was a really keen on seeing a live
classical music show but now
I might go see a bit more
[Music]
well that's it for this week and don't
forget if you have a story or want to
report for FYI head to our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI see you
next time bye
[Music]